the third season of stranger things was
a ton of fun but that doesn't mean it
was flawless so we're breaking down
season 3 to find the high points and the
low points from interminable bickering -
fresh comic relief here are the three
best and three worst things about
stranger things season 3 making things
bigger is a classic element of
serialized cinema simply put you can't
go on entertaining the masses with the
same stuff that hooked them in the first
place show runners directors and
producers are always working on ways to
make things newer better and badder on
top of that the third season is an
interesting point in any series as it
serves as a transition point of sorts on
the one hand it typically connects to
original plots from the beginning of the
show while on the other hand attempts
reorient and expand the story to keep
things entertaining and map out future
possibilities this is always a difficult
task but in the case of stranger things
season 3 the production crew has
actually managed to calibrate and
graduate the story to greater heights
without losing the cozy small-town feel
of the first season season 3 clearly has
some pretty big fish to fry
like the invasion of the mind flayer and
the unveiling of a huge Russian base
underneath Hawkins however it
masterfully balances his major plot
points with a healthy dose of carnival
fun trips to the mall a deep dive into
the relationships of walk with teenagers
and even a hilarious reference to the
massively overblown New Coke fiasco how
do you even drink that because it's
delicious what it's incredibly sweet to
watch his eleven in mic day to break up
and then find their way back to each
other
Lucas and Max get in on the fun - with
their stage relationship advice Plus
Dustin keeps us endlessly entertained as
he loyally maintains a season-long quest
to link up with Suzy think phoebe cates
only hotter but there's one relationship
throughout the series that's just
beating a dead horse we're talking of
course about the unspoken attraction at
disgust tension whatever you want to
call it between chief Jim hopper and
Joyce buyers the two opened flirting
since the earliest days of the show and
by the end of season 3 they still
haven't managed to hook up or call it
off season 2 had Bob Newby Joyce's
boyfriend to ease attention and served
as a natural barrier between the two
characters there was no such firewall in
season 3 and the banter the two engaged
in as they travel together got older
really fast listen to Alexei alright
yeah
your new boyfriend right
every man I talk to from now on has to
be my boyfriend just Marie Bauman said
it best in Episode seven children
children this interminable bickering was
amusing at first but it's getting very
stale Lucas and Claire's little sister
was in season two but season three is
where a star really shines
Erica Sinclair is all sass and sharp
comebacks Erica is also a keen
negotiator as the kids plan to
infiltrate the secret Russian operation
within the mall they attempt to recruit
the little Hellraiser due to a smaller
physique as she can crawl through the
air ducts sensing an opportunity erica
has them bring all of the ice cream she
could possibly desire as they discuss a
potential involvement
Erica ends up being a steady presence
throughout the season nearly always
delivering a bit of comic relief that
cuts through the tension like butter her
bump in screen time isn't an accident
either in an interview with vulture
after season two it just dropped whiter
and director mad duffer said she totally
earned it revealing any excuse we had to
get Erica in there would write her in
the characters role in season three is
so entertaining and scene-stealing that
even pushed Entertainment Weekly to top
her the MVP of the season one of the
hallmark features of the stranger things
storyline is the occasional trips that
he upside down the first two seasons
feature multiple forays into that gloomy
dangerous inverted world the third
season goes there too as Billy Hargrove
meets his otherworldly counterpart just
after his mind is played but after that
the upside down nearly leaves a story
entirely to be fair it makes sense after
all the mind player is doing his level
best throughout the season to invade the
normal right-side-up world
it follows how the majority of the
season would take place in the real
world as the flayed carry out their
masters bidding and former bloody
mutilated mega corpse for it to use
nevertheless the lack of time spent on
the upside down in season three ends up
being a bit of a disappointment
throughout the season the possibility of
running into demo Gorgons or demo dogs
in their own element remains firmly out
of reach instead the utter and complete
mystery of the upside-down remains just
that a mystery
conspiracy theorist Marie bellman
appeared earlier in the series when he
was hired as a private investigator by
the Holland's to find their missing
daughter fan favorite Barbara from there
he ended up helping Nancy wheeler and
Jonathan Byers as they attempted to
expose a Hawkins National Laboratory
what
doing thinking with vodka it's a central
nervous system depressants oh yes
Bauman's role was fun but shallow at
best until season 3 much like Erica
Sinclair season 3 sees Baumann become a
much bigger player his character is
integral to the entire second half of
the season as he gives asylum to Harper
and Joyce helps infiltrate the Russian
base under the star Court mall and
translates for Alexei who quickly
becomes Murray's friend Murray sweet but
short-lived relationship with Alexei was
a surprise friendship of the season on
par with Dustin and Steve's unlikely
bond too bad poor Alexei didn't survive
the carnival Murray who's typically a
loner really seemed to take a liking to
the guy you should have sex scene yep
hopper is awesome the dude is nearly as
good as stopping bad guys as he is bad
at being a parent but the truth is he's
a small-town law enforcement officer not
Rambo and the endless stream of villains
he takes on throughout season three gets
way out of hand when you add it all up
from an ongoing string of fist fights
and shootouts with the Russians to its
multi-episode door the Soviet equivalent
of the Terminator hopper comes across as
an unstoppable juggernaut in season 3 no
matter how badly each fight goes he
always comes back for more no matter how
beat up he is by the next episode he's
swinging away like he's selling round 1
even the fact that he may have survived
the explosion and the Russian base an
offender vaporized Soviet agent standing
much further away from the blast boggles
the imagination Plus why did he wait
until the events of episode 6 to call
for backup considering he was getting
his butt kicked and running from Russian
soldiers multiple episodes prior because
your policemen policemen have rules
Tesla Theory check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]